we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p very often
voicemails are ugly voicemails are toxic
voicemails represent sort of the worst
from the audience i have a complete
departure from that for you today i have
just like a wholesome really nice
voicemail from a little kid who says
that the david pakman show has really
done great things for their family take
a listen to this hello I just like to
say I like your show and yeah so hello
David Pakman and thank you for all you
done for my family and it really helped
us and like time of need said hey bye I
love it I absolutely love it there is
nothing more wholesome than that I'd
love to know more about how I've helped
this kids family so if you want to call
back in please do but every once in a
while it's nice to get out of the
cesspool that is 99% of the feedback
that this program gets and to get
something just genuinely nice from a
nice person in the audience so thank you
and I really appreciate the kind words
we've got a great bonus show for you
today Donald Trump is starting the
effort to try to flip Minnesota we'll
talk about how he's doing it
many many myths continue to spread like
a virus about sleep for humans and what
humans need and what constitutes good
sleep and lastly a GoFundMe scammer who
collected four hundred thousand dollars
is facing four years in prison all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access by becoming a
member at WWE and pakman.com or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I'll speak to you then
otherwise that's it for today